I am going to keep my introductions
minimal so that we can be sure to hear
the most from our speakers so I'm going
to invite people to to look in your
course book which has BIOS for our
presenters I will say that I it is my
privilege to work side-by-side with our
next expert in our in our Yale program
at our Adult Day Program I invite dr.
Gabriela Volf to come up to the podium
and join us just got introducing
borderline person I disorder to us but
also letting us hear about challenges of
working with psychotic experience that
can rise thank you dr. Boff
thank you very much Seth good morning
keep this in mind because I'm gonna ask
you about it later
as a full disclaimer everybody has to
make their own disclaimers I'm not a big
researcher the people who preceded me
the people who follow me they are I'm
not dr. Axelrod asked me to come here
and talk from my experience as a
clinician so please keep your Q&A in
this area I was fortunate enough to have
listened to a lot of stories people came
to me with I prescribed a lot of
medications I had good luck bad luck
with some and then I listened back to
the stories people brought me about
those so this is the position I'm
talking from the first time when I
realized that cognitive problems can be
an issue was a weird episode years ago
I'm not going to say how many when I was
still an internist and there was a kind
lady who I liked a lot she liked me who
came to the office she was extremely
upset and she made she made my staff
miserable she praised me she said that
I'm the best doctor she's ever seen but
that she's not gonna come to this office
any longer because she was so upset with
stuff and we talked a lot we established
some things and at the next visit I was
shocked to see that she didn't remember
much of that upset she had about day
remarks she made honestly she didn't so
this is the first time and I realized
that intuitively it's not the is not
worth to talk a lot when people are
extremely upset yeah go figure and then
later on in my psychiatry residency I
learned strike the iron when it's cold
but that made sense
then I became very very interested in
when Seth proposed this topic I said yes
so here is what I learned about it I'm
going to tell you all about what I know
about borderline personality about why
is this diagnosis so challenging
why primary care doctors don't put it
why we don't make it in emergency rooms
and such why we don't explain it what's
this problem about the cognitive issues
some challenges where I encounter when I
treat people and some good news too so
let's go ahead there are several ways to
think about borderline personality the
official way is the DSM this is our
Bible and next week next Sunday is going
to be the fifth edition and just by the
way the criteria for borderline
personality won't change from the
previous the fourth edition TR so for
some reason they said there are there
five criteria out of nine I don't know
what happens when you have four criteria
out of nine and these four seem
important like self-harm or feeling
empty or angry or dissociated nobody
knows on the other hand this is what
angers me about the research is that can
be arbitrary and can rely upon previous
research that could have been flawed so
one of the reporters from psychiatry
News tracked down the person who was
part of the first task force that
participated in the DSM first writing
and asked about the criteria for
depression which as you know there's
still five out of nine how did you come
up with five out of nine what kind of
curves and what kind of ROC curves you
use to figure that out and that person
said seemed about right true story
we'll talk about it later dr. Linehan
smaadahl made a lot more sense to me and
she's so pragmatic this lady so she
identified some areas that have problems
this area of this regulation like
emotional cognitive and her personal and
she proposes some solutions for that and
then you have in my school you have to
learn about the psychodynamic model and
actually make sense to think about how
people think about themselves how they
perceive reality and what do they do
when they're stressed out how do they
cope with stress and then finally dr.
Herman and dr. van der Kolk talk about
borderline personality as a complex post
traumatic stress
so dsm is talking about these nine
criteria about the abandonment about
these stormy relationships about
problems thinking about yourself as a
sole person but in being impulsive
suicidal at times being emotionally
unstable feeling empty sometimes angry
and also like my lady then I realized
she must have dissociated she honestly
didn't remember anything from what
happened in that visit well these were
too many lines to remember so I'm a very
pragmatic person and I'm prefer
mnemonics like dr. Linehan would and
this is what I have for you
I'm suicide and this is how I can
remember the criteria there has to do
with the Bandon men mood swings suicide
unstable relationships difficulty
controlling anger emptiness you have
them all so now you remember the three
words remember the song this is for me
to help me remember things and what I
realized is that songs have a lot to do
with unstable emotions very intense
emotions and this song particularly
which I love has all the criteria in DSM
because it's a song about relationships
right talks about the Bannerman's talks
about emptiness about impulsivity and
substance abuse so risky behaviors some
paranoid ideation over there self-harm
rather than feeling numb right
a sense of identity let's move on to dr.
Linehan model this is a speaker who's
been here before Kyra Van Gelder she is
extremely talented and she can put in
she can explain things in a way that I
can always understand and remember
forever so I borrowed one of her slides
that has to do with explaining what
borderline personality is about and she
identifies the three first areas of this
regulation that dr. Linehan indicates
emotions impulsive impulsive nests in
relationships and she adds the
self-image in cognition now dr. Linehan
is very pragmatic she invented this
phenomenal method of treating people
that works the electrical behavioral
therapy and suffice us to say that we're
very good at that
dr. Axelrod can say a lot more about it
let's move on to them my school's model
and this actually made a lot more sense
than DSM to me because you cannot really
label people describe them and then put
them on shelves put them in nice shoe
boxes and say here does your this your
blue your green your size is 14 whatever
so rather people are functioning across
a continuum and I agree we're all nuts I
am sometimes smarter than others and the
question is how severe is the nuttiness
and in what flavor so here's how these
people explain it and the best way to
put it I really like visuals I think
that 80% of the information we transmit
via visual so look how I think about it
you have these neurotic healthy people
who are very structured and very
organized over here right and then you
have here the psychotic people who are
loose whose boundaries are very very
very loose very fluid for instance over
here and a neurotic healthy individual
would say well staff is pushing me
sometimes he sounds like my father who
is pushing me but he's a very good
mentor and I'm gonna pick up this
challenge and I'm going to
something about it over here ah Seth he
is my father I'm gonna just disintegrate
I cannot stand this kind of challenge
and I'm going to this is a loose
boundary loose sense of self where I am
and where self begins and this is the
borderline personality level
organization where you can have parts of
you that are very very organized and a
very structure you appear very competent
and parts of our loser and then come the
flavors so here you have the depressive
people so this is me on a good day then
then you have paranoid people here you
have this a head of the CIA who else
let's see sociopaths here you have some
famous CEOs over here right here and
then you have the obsessive-compulsive
and so forth so this actually makes a
lot more sense to me that people would
have different degrees of functioning
they would not be able to keep their
lives together they would have a lot of
struggles with that and suffer a lot and
people who would be able or luckier and
they they have it easier this is how
Nancy McWilliams writes about it and she
writes about the sense of identity this
is basically where I stop and Seth
begins this is the defense's that the
coping mechanisms that people use and
this is how I see reality is Seth really
angry with me because he didn't tell me
that my slides are fabulous now he
doesn't have time to tell me that my
slides are fabulous in terms of
primitive defenses this is a fascinating
area so I was always impressed how what
people use in interactions and for
instance one of the main coping
mechanisms that people with borderline
personality use is splitting you've
heard about it right now this is not the
splitting that you hear
the team morning report that all this
person who splits all the time it's not
about that it's how people who have
borderline personality view the world so
when I have borderline personality I
cannot hold in my head the idea that my
mom can have some good parts and bad
parts or like dr. Barth can be
phenomenal and know all these
medications and she could be late she
has some flaws so the idea is that if
you think about kids they have the same
problem they cannot hold in their idea
their head the idea that people can get
good be good and bad and you see this in
fairy tales actually in fairy tales
you have the stepmom and the good mom
who's usually dead anyway but here you
have the stepmom who's all bad a good
mom is all good and they cannot coexist
but actually they're the same person is
the mom but the kids need the splitting
to understand that's why people with
borderline cannot receive in a moment
people can be either very good or very
bad there's nothing in between now the
last model I'm going to talk briefly
about is the complex post-traumatic
stress model and depends when drama the
abuse happened in life and can be drama
with big t like horrendous sexual abuse
or can be a small T trauma like Francine
Shapiro would say can be just bullying
just being invalidated all the time
so here's after Hurricane Irene in my
backyard this is the trees you have some
branches here they're they're broken but
these trees are standing and this
happened late in their development
what's this this is a tree that has an
identity that trauma being bent all the
time by this continuous pressure from
outside this has entered into its
identity the previous trees are ordinary
trees that are trees in my backyard
this one is the divi divi tree in Aruba
so this is its identity it's bent
forever because the wind always blows in
the same direction that's why another
way to think about it is how you grow
with trauma and
with these cognitions these ideas that
you hold about yourself that were
inputted from outside see how they are
growing into you and if you take them
apart very quickly and without
preparation guess what happens right now
how many people are we talking about
they were saying in the clip before 15
million this is a very very answer is
depends basically depending on what
sample you use this is a very large
community sample this is 35,000 people
and the results of which were published
in February this is in general
population basically three out of a
hundred people will have more line
personality Native Americans more Asian
less in a hospital setting two out of
five so what's the problem why why's
bother so much with the not diagnosing
properly and thinking of it and treating
it sounds so simple because it's not
because overlaps with so much this is
the problem that I have a studies too is
viscous usually they select the
population that's relatively clear of
overlapping problems and here you have
the depression you have the bipolar the
substance abuse like it was mentioned
earlier you have the anxiety disorders
and PTSD is one of them and you have the
psychosis these are the numbers and
again I'm not the number person I can
tell you for instance impress you and
say oh look mood disorder you're 14
percent 14 times more likely to have a
mood disorder or I can impress you and
say look at the antisocial or like
schizotypal how many times more likely
to have a comorbid condition with that
but I'm a visual person so look what I
prepared for you from the same community
example you have a lot of systems abuse
seventy eight point two percent of
people were found to have substance
abuse problems do you know why just
because they won't know because they're
treating a condition actually here's the
mood disorder here's the anxiety
remember part of it is post-traumatic
stress then in other studies everything
depends on that studies you're looking
at you'll find ADHD and here comes the
overlap with the cognition problems that
we have how much of it is dissociation
how much of is a post-traumatic stress
where people cannot focus because of the
trauma and the anxiety how much is true
attention deficit then you have the
learning disability and doctors and
Harini three years ago was talking a lot
about the eating disorders right over
here overlaps a lot with access to so
you have here's your paranoid your
antisocial your narcissistic and when
you see so much overlap doesn't my
watery example makes make more sense
where you have different degrees of
organization in the red flavors I put it
on its own because regardless of what we
talked earlier this is the admission
diagnosis guess what this is what I have
to write when I admit you at the
hospital otherwise the insurance won't
pay me any money
the truth is psychotic disorder per se
is just in one percent overlap with the
borderline personality but this gets to
be access one because otherwise the
hospital doesn't get paid if you think
of it you can stretch and say well this
makes sense sometimes people don't have
good reality testing their moods are
fluctuating most biscuits effective
right then you can think well but why
not simply bipolar and Gundersen and the
Atletico would say that maybe the soft
bipolar spectrum disorder with extremely
rapid cycling however people who have
borderline tend to fluctuate and
negative they think negatively about
them and they don't quite have this I
feel good I'm the best kind of feeling
that people with mania do in emptiness
that flavor of depression prevails and
not feeling guilty and ashamed so much
and the mood lability this comes from
outside some they're extremely reactive
is like they have third-degree burn on
their skin and everything hurts hurts
immensely and actually this intensity of
hurt is what is a good indicator this is
what Santorini say about the pain of
being borderline I respect a lot and
admire the people who had the courage to
explain to me what this pain means and
how they feel worthless abandoned
enraged and how they feel misunderstood
so as treaters please keep this in mind
is this complex PTSD
well the neuroimaging could say that
definitely if you look at volumes and
you measure and you die with certain
colors definitely can look like complex
PTSD so let's talk about this cognitive
issue that fascinates me and again a
slide from Kyra Van Gelder where she
puts all the main ones here you have
your black and white thinking here you
have your paranoid thinking here you
have seen people either all good or all
bad when I read post traumatic stress
books dissociation books this is what I
came up with and this is one of the main
problems that appears the cognitive
distortions that go all along so this is
the black and white thinking the denial
this is not happening to me the
projection of self is angered angry at
me is not that I'm afraid he is angry
dissociation this is what happened to my
lady and can be either contained primary
dissociation with nightmares and
flashbacks or you can have it this
out-of-body experience when you're
watching yourself when something bad
happens and you know don't want to
experience it yourself or when it's very
severe and trauma occurred very very
early you will see that people develop
alters the multiple personality disorder
some people in my school may say I don't
believe in that i I've met it they do
exist because they're multiples and
psychosis so here's the catch with
psychosis what my understanding of it
and from my discussions with dr. Hoffman
who's my partner at IOP and who is an
expert in psychosis and schizophrenia
psychosis and borderline personality has
to do with the splitting you cannot
admit that these negative thoughts are
yours so they're from outside and there
is a something different about their
flavor they're not coming from somewhere
in a room so people with the borderline
where they won't be tempted to turn
around and say well who's in the room
with me no they usually hear it in their
head and usually it's a familiar voice
people who they know parents
in psychosis they can be familiar people
but can be others from around or
strangers that say a negative things and
really they turn around to see as if
that voices are coming from outside of
the head the best explanation ever for
this cognitive perceptual disturbances I
got it from a person who I'm going to
name Stacy so again I'm grateful that
she took the time to explain to me
we had a coaching call one night and I
poured so much wisdom I had so many good
ideas and what to do and Seth with a bit
so proud of me the next day then the
next day she comes she hadn't done
anything from what we talked about she
didn't remember talking to me on a phone
so what's going on and then she
explained this to me and I'm forever
grateful
so she said see for you reality is like
this and she draws a straight line for
me reality is like this she draws these
interrupted the lines so if you catch me
in between
I cannot remember and then all of a
sudden the light bulb went off you know
so this is really and truly what happens
when your dysregulated you can't you
don't have good touch with the previous
memories this is the mood dependent
memory people cannot possibly access
their memories of the other person's
about the discussions and here's my
favorite song again you have these
memories but they are scattered they're
not linked together and this is true is
actually in people's heads this is a
famous experiment with faces and the
reactions they have on normal controls
and borderline people do you see the
difference I mean really this is this is
real it's not that people try to
manipulate those treaters this is for
real so I chose these pictures because
again they're worth a thousand words and
we can have more understanding for
what's going on these are structures
that are involved and I'm going to ask
you to remember just three this is the
Magdala this is our emotional Center
this is what tells us this is important
I remember this and this is going to
trigger a lot
things this is the prefrontal cortex
this is what is going to tell me how
much I'm going to act upon these
emotions this is going to direct my
behavior I'm going to be contained or
I'm going to fall apart and this is the
hippocampus this is where I store my
cognitive map this is how I make sense
of what happened before and I can choose
to behave accordingly so this is the
really very bassist I'm going to be very
simple about that and in dr. van der Cox
book dramatic stress we have this
wonderful slide this is the best light
really I made such an extensive
literature's for search for this
conference and this is the first slide
where actually they show how information
flows from one Center to another so let
me give you some good news first the bad
news the guidelines are old twelve years
old still on the APA side we have a
guideline start from 2001 where they're
saying just treat the symptoms basically
if you have the cognitive problems you
do this and this and this you have them
in your handout if you have emotional
disturbances you do this and this and
this and if you have angry so basically
the three clusters of symptoms you do
this and this and this well six years
later the World Federation didn't do
much better they were similar in
guidelines with the APA plus they were
discouraging benzos so this is my big
problem with benzos because this is a
chronic condition and we're creating
monsters and actually xanax is one of
the main ones because can have this
serious disc control side effect in
England people were even more radical
they said ah we don't advise you to
treat anything that treatment should not
be used specifically for this disorder
for symptoms or for self-harm okay so
what are we supposed to do so 2010 is
the last review Cochrane is our most
respected database of guidelines and
they took 10,000 studies out of which
only these were well conducted and they
came up with these ideas so this is one
of the three main slides that I'm going
to tell you about you treat the
cognitive perceptual symptoms with two
antipsychotics were shown to be really
really good
vilify and zyprexa cyber excel I have a
big caveat about it will come down in a
second anger and impulsivity remember
topamax abilify and lamotrigine Haldol
emotional dysregulation you have some
amitriptyline again see yours Ibrox
abilify fish oil actually this is so
benign i said i'm going to implement it
for suicide self-harm again you see the
fish oil and for interpersonal problems
again abilify topamax there's not enough
evidence but they're so benign clonidine
for the self-harm for the anger for
anxiety and now tricks on for basically
like one of my mentors told me anything
that has to do with the pleasure you can
block it you can block the endorphins
with the naltrexone
so remember keywords abilify topamax
clonidine all tracks and fish oil this
is what actually happens not too many
psychiatrists are taking on borderline
personality disorders so if i am to
remain official and be a blank slate I
would lie to you officially there's only
one study that says Gundersen in 2011
that psychiatrist don't take on
borderline patients and to be very
honest this was something that pained me
a lot because I like working with
borderlines I think they're caring and I
think they're extremely talented and
hurt me to learn in my last year of
school that when somebody was very
successful to give us tips how to have a
successful practice screen out the
borderlines really so I decided to be
transparent and tell you what's going on
that's why you don't find psychiatrists
who were take on so let's go to the
medication piece what do we choose and
there are some problems with
non-adherence so that's why I don't
quite like Lamech doe because takes
forever to titrate and people may forget
or be too upset to take it
it is the overdose potential and you
would say well I'm not going to
prescribe a level then well if it's a
good medication I'm going to treat you
as my partner
you're an adult I'm gonna tell you don't
overdose on it but I'm gonna still
prescribe it because it's good for you
so I trust you and have clear targets
especially when you have these cognitive
distortions that all-or-nothing
people would say forever I don't feel
good never worked for me nothing ever
worked for me so just be clear and I
learned from my psychology friends to
put numbers on it nonetheless people end
up on many medications this is an actual
list this is real 20-something
medications on this one this is what
people end up on and neuroleptics this
they're very dirty medications they
don't go many receptors and that's why
you're going to have so good effects and
bad effects you're going to find on your
handouts how we pick and choose based on
side effects and what to expect this is
a list that I put together starting from
dr. Stahl psychopharmacology and
monographs for each medication and this
is a question that everybody asked me
and I could only put it together from
dozens dozens of studies and monographs
because I wanted to put first generation
and second generation relatives in one
slide so here's my abilify do you see it
remember and that's why I don't like zip
Rexha here it is 9.2 pounds gained in
three months if you're lucky and this is
led to DES the newer one which are
partly is more efficient than geodon
which I'm not sure how much it works
everybody asked me about weight and you
cannot predict who's gonna win
who's gonna gain and not is not those
related it's very difficult to lose
whomever had problems with the weight
gain you can say that this is very hard
to lose they have problems with heart
and I wonder how many of us we actually
do check I don't check waste that's
another disclaimer but I do send people
for their EKGs and I ask people to and
for their labs and I ask people to stick
their tongue at me periodically this is
the Ames test we're doing really loudly
with the check-in things this is after
the guidelines came out this is how
we're doing with treaters so this is a
big
cry for doing better hours our part and
because this is this chasm between the
guidelines between mean we know what we
have to do it we don't do it because we
are part of the equation we may be
burned out too and then we do this so
let me tell you the good news and this
is going to be the end of the practical
things I'm going to say metformin works
metformin is a medication that is
initially used for diabetes but also
works for the weight gain in some
studies you can even prevent seven kilos
from being put on and topamax works a
tip about metformin if started slowly a
lot of people tell me that they cannot
tolerate because they're started with
500 twice a day when actually that the
whole trick is to start it slowly to 50
once a day for a week then you start 250
twice a day you titrate it slowly to
avoid the area if that still happens you
switch on the extended-release and that
people tolerate much better topamax
really works and the cognitive
distortions that the cognitive problems
that can appear they're reversible so is
worth a shot other medications we use
well this is always a problem with the
co-pays this is my cheat sheet this is
how I pick and choose my antidepressants
do you want less sexual side-effects I'm
going to give you lexapro do you want
let's say more sedation I can choose
between symbol time and effexor
everybody's asking me about weight gain
so this is my answer to that and I can
tell you about some tips for instance
lamictal my neurology friends would say
fifty twice a day then 100 twice a day
the next week okay abilify started slow
because of the akathisia what else for
the comorbid ad D set some goals not
just the overall goal just to feel and
better use the long-acting formulation
in the morning and then when people get
home and they have to take care of the
kids the short-acting remember to use
some cardiovascular medications my
patients know that I prefer propranolol
stage fright for anxiety
clonidine guanfacine but for people who
use cocaine this is a biggie and the way
to remember don't prescribe propanol or
for people beta-blockers for people who
use cocaine because you can cause
strokes and heart attacks so the way to
remember there's no B in cocaine okay
and the ECT is always an issue and if
you have severe comorbid depression it
works now measure everything you do put
it on a slide don't interupt things
during holidays and about sleep let me
tell them about sleep hypnotics this is
a big problem so last year in February
this was this big study that came out so
we should be more careful when we
prescribe because we can cut off
people's years of life so everybody
should be on a schedule should limit
their distractions should eliminate this
TV from the bedroom these are not my
kids my kids will never watch TV in
their bedroom and anyway what you're
going to see this is what you see
exercise spirituality so please patients
please ask your doctors about choices be
informed consumers your partners in this
you are my partner so remember the key
words
abilify topamax Quan Dino tracks and
fish oil ask your doctor to send you
four labs to check your weight
dear treater remember where you're
starting from meet people where they are
pay attention to yourself and family
members towards family connections these
are very good references I'm giving you
and thank you patients everybody for
educating me and my mentors for teaching
me that there's always hope
Thank You dr. ball III have two words
great slides okay we have a couple of a
couple of quick announcements to add one
is our process for asking questions
hopefully people heard I should have
announced earlier is to write your
questions on green index cards pass them
to the aisles one thing to be aware of
is that in addition to questions that
can come immediately following the
presentation we will have the entire
panel discussion time will also be a
time to send in questions which could be
directed to individuals or could be
directed to multiple individuals we will
have limited question answer time on on
these first couple of presentations to
get us back on track time wise but we
will take a few questions dr. Bob I also
want to mention as this is going if
people would be willing to move in
toward the middle in the seating just
because we have had more people come in
and would like to allow them to come
into the auditorium so I'd appreciate it
if people would be willing to shift
around okay first question is would you
say a word about how you think a patient
a client with borderline personality
disorder would do after bariatric
surgery and particularly with regard to
issues of poor self-image or unstable
sense of self yes this is one of my
favorite topics actually when I used to
be an internist I sent 53 people for
bariatric surgery 52 had it I'm doing
all the preoperative screenings for
bariatric surgery in the primary care
centers and works you can get rid of the
diabetes you can improve your self-image
I don't see it as the last resort this
is after your diabetes there's a rig hey
buck in your body this is a great great
option and again be good partners and
this ask your doctor about it ask them
to be sent because the risks are so
minimal and the benefits just absolutely
huge I don't have other cards reach me
it's possibly because I didn't I didn't
make the announcement earlier
I would expect people will have
questions about this presentation and
again if you jot them down or if they
occur to you during the day the panel
discussion would be a place where we
could have more questions coming right
now we don't I'm going to say thank you
so much dr. Boff